I'm Levy Rosman you might know me as
Gotham chess today I've been challenged
with the task of explaining chess in
five levels of increasing difficulty
chess is an absolutely fascinating game
think of it as a language it's
completely Timeless it's been around for
thousands of years it's also completely
ageless a lot of people who are going to
watch this video have never played chess
before how would you explain chess to
them I would start off with the basics
by teaching them how to move the pieces
like the pawns Knights Queens Bishops
Kings what's the goal of the whole game
well the goal of the game is trap the
king and attack it at the same time yes
so it can't run away yeah exactly and
also take all of their pieces yeah for
me I would describe chess as a lot of
what you said and also it's a mix of
really quick plans like tactics and then
things that can take four five six seven
moves like like a plan like a strategy
so let's practice in this position I had
the white pieces you're playing on my
side my opponent was playing with the
black pieces so we switched a little bit
so if I said hey you get three moves in
a row can you come up with a plan I
think I could if I have three moves in a
row I'd probably Checkmate them with
Rook H3 Queen H4 and then Queen takes H7
Checkmate I'm very happy that's the
first plan that you came up with right
you can bring your queen out this way or
the Rook you can start with both and
then you come here and then you
Checkmate but I did say white gets three
moves in a row right but that's how we
have to think about plans right we have
to think about okay well if I get a
couple of moves in a row what would I
like to accomplish what does my opponent
want to do so I'm not just going to sit
here and get checkmated hopefully right
so what do you think I want to do in
this position I think my king is on bad
scare right now so maybe you're trying
to like trade and then somehow get an
attack on my king oh you're saying like
if I take this Pawn maybe in the future
I'll try to open up this diagonal to
that's that's very good Vision there's
some pieces in the way but yes in chess
you have to always keep an eye on what
can possibly open do you know how you
can tell whether a position is closed or
open usually when a position is closed
pieces are more squished together the
easiest way by far to figure out if a
position is closed is how many pawns do
we eat Che right now it's eight so think
of it like a fence right so if you and
your neighbor have a full fence you
can't really see each other but if
there's only four pawns that means
somebody probably knocked down half of
the fence right so if we start picking
up all these pawns then the position is
more open so this would be a close
position this type of strategy would be
called an attacking strategy cuz you
found a way to get your queen and Rook
down this line against my king before we
even talk about what tactic is here who
does it look like is winning this game I
think White's winning okay why do you
think so well the black king is very
exposed into the white side of the board
and like the white king is a bit more
safe yes you're 100% right cuz in chess
the two most important things we have to
think about are who has more material
but then like you said who has the
weaker King and I would say my King has
gone way too far right so there's a
tactic here for white um maybe is it
Bishop takes Pawn on before so that's
like immediately you get a reward but
I'll give you a hint the best way to
start looking for a tactic always look
for a check first do you have a way to
attack my king yes look H1 so exactly
you would give me that check now where
can my king go let's just try to think
um your king can go to King D4 yes
that's my only move so I would go here
now what else is on that diagonal um the
look yes and which of your pieces can
the bishop the bishop so so do you know
what this type of tactic is called a
skuba yes well done and then I would
take the pawn and then I would take the
rook and then you would take the Rook
now the funny thing is you are now
totally winning right but as we know in
chess maybe one day white will make a
mistake in the future so there's no
point for black to surrender here but
this is definitely a really good
[Music]
start how long have you been playing
chess I played a little bit of Chess
growing up against my brothers but ever
since the Queen's Gambit show came out
that's I think when I downloaded
downloaded the app and started playing
against friends for fun so chess has
separated into three games obviously you
have your opening which is the early
stage of the game then we have the
middle game right the most confusing
mysterious side of the game and and the
end game where there's no pieces
remaining on the board you got to have
to know how to convert positions defend
positions understand how to play the
game with only five pieces remaining or
something like that so for you what do
you struggle with the most yeah I would
say I really struggle in the mid game I
feel like I've developed most of my
pieces try to control the center but at
a certain point I'm a little bit stuck
on like okay now what what do I do so
I'm going to look up your account we're
going to pick a game and we're going to
analyze it sounds good in all middle
games we have this mix of tactics which
are immediate gain or immediate loss
depending on if we're getting hit with a
tactic or playing one and strategic
chess I just want you to tell me who do
you think has a better position here and
by how much to me right now it feels
pretty even like there's no major
vulnerabilities from both sides but I
guess the white pieces the pieces are a
little bit more developed I would say
everything you just said is 100%
accurate so that's one of those Baseline
pieces of information that we need for
the middle game I have the two Bishops
how can I activate one of my Bishops you
have a little plan you could actually
Implement right now that would make one
of your Bishops extremely strong you
think you can find it if I had a guess I
think it probably moving this bishop
here you definitely want to get the
bishop out but you don't want to move it
just yet so how do you do that I am not
sure this is how we unlock the
intermediate level which is this move
that move looks like it's disconnecting
from the whole board right it's a move
totally on the edge but nobody is going
to stop your Bishop from going to that
diagonal and then you're threatening a
tactic yeah you're threatening a skewer
you would hit my queen and my Rook
stronger piece in front weaker piece in
back and then you would be guaranteed to
win some material just like little
pattern recognition in the middle game
so for the future you're going to have a
game where your opponent makes same
trade early right they trade their dark
squired bishop and you can activate it
like that but in this game you focused
on the center which was totally fine
also maybe one question I have is like
as I'm also looking at this position
just trying to understand like okay what
is my opponent trying to do here one
thing to always monitor in every chess
middle game is does my opponent have a
pawn break can my opponent strike
somewhere with a pawn that would open up
the board if you have a lowrisk position
your position's just nice and
comfortably better you don't want chaos
I guess maybe they would try to advance
their middle Pawn yes and this move is
actually very annoying for white because
not only am I now targeting things in
your Center what else have I changed
just by moving this Pawn uh now their
Bishop is activated yesh another thing
for Middle games so we just keep adding
to that bucket of knowledge Pawn breaks
for the opponent and then every time
something moves like a pawn we have to
look around what else is now opening up
and we want to get to a situation where
you knew this move was going to and then
next I'm going to come here and then now
what can I do I can bring both my Rooks
M and now I have no problems right now I
have both Knights Queen Rooks so we need
to get to a point where we see that
coming and we're not just focusing on
our own plans but that's not always easy
so with Pawn here that disrupts my plan
yeah right because now this move fails
to yeah respond to the skewer yes as
you're trying to improve your middle
game one question you always have to ask
yourself is is that trade good for me is
it good for my opponent opponent it's
not Checkers you don't have to take me
and I don't have to take you so we can
do something called keeping the tension
we're just having a staring contest here
among the pawns so I'm going to ask you
do you think it's better for black to
capture this Pawn or keep the tension
just slide The Rook over and threaten to
push the pawn here which would be a
tactic and a fork if I was black I would
Advance the pawn because I think knowing
that black has two knights and I have
have two Bishops they would want more of
a closed game yes but before we advance
we need we need to prepare it right
because you push it now right these two
would win that trade so yeah rookie 8 is
is is a very good move you used kind of
like a Uris right well black has two
knights so black prefers the position
closed because the side with the Bishops
wants to be able to see the whole board
yes exactly but your opponent disagreed
with you and took this Pawn Yeah because
that's just what intermediate players do
they see they can take something Pawn
for Pawn what the heck like sure and you
did this now what does this move change
in the white position so that opened up
the diagonal for my dark Square Bishop
yep here yeah and what else what else
did that move open up uh it opened up
the E file for us yes exactly so now in
the snap of your fingers you can get
your Bishop out and a rook two things
that a move ago were just totally
blocked in by a pawn exactly so in the
middle game trades are either good or
bad for you and for your opponent mhm
you know I'm in the mid game right now
but what do I need to do or learn in
order to take it up another level to a
more advanced player style it's a lot of
practice and Analysis really an advanced
chess player was not born an advanced
chess player they have probably hundreds
if not thousands of more games in their
mind in their past in their history that
they've analyzed that they've studied
it's like any athlete you know I put my
weight on this foot and so I wasn't able
to hit the shot back that well so the
next time that that happens I'm going to
be more
prepared I'm wearing a black hoodie
black pants you definitely have more
style than me today so in chess people
have style too yeah what's your playing
style I'm I'll say quite aggressive like
I really want to win the game fast so as
we move up the levels today we want to
start introducing slightly more advanced
terms one of them is called initiative
but what exactly does that mean to you
so like if you're in a battle you win a
certain spot right a really important
spot that gives you initiative when you
get something right that you want then
it can start building up it can start
building up to be better and better
bigger and bigger when you find a Target
and you have a way to create threats
attacks against that Target against that
goal but you do it without sacrificing
your resources right so imagine two
boxers right one is being pushed into a
corner he could still win he could
totally still win but for now one side
is definitely the aggressor and have an
issue exactly has the initiative you're
a tactical aggressive player you're
always looking for the initiative me too
why don't we play a Blitz game good luck
look
okay okay that's not the opening I
remember you
playing we've played in the park we've
played online wonder how many games we
played against each other um we've
played I think probably like including
over theb and online maybe like 9 10
games
[Music]
okay so we have like just like a regular
finetto
see this is not the ttin I remember T
it's quite slow it's a very solid you
know steady approach there's nothing
wrong with
it okay let's see very balanced actually
I had this chest opening really
recently and I lost that game and it was
very painful and very sad I feel like
black has more
space would you say black has more
initiative not yet not yet but
considering the way I said it it's like
you follow up of something so you just
attack my D and I move back so you kind
of you have the initiative the tough
thing about Chess is you can have a good
position but you actually have to move
pieces you know like a piece of art you
just say oh it's done so chess is
different from art chest is different
from art let's go here we go here okay
let's go here okay let's
see I'll go here just in case I don't I
don't know let's okay I'm just going to
like take more space from you is this
quite like a just a wow just a position
you know what we've been talking about
initiative I think I just got to go for
it I just got to like got to push all my
pawns that could be good that could be
bad I I have to deal with it at some
point no you don't wow wow just in case
cuz I feel like my position is it's like
a fortress so feels like I can do moves
like Rook H1 doesn't help my position if
you don't attack but think it's just
good to be just steady I'm
stunned okay you know what I'm going to
go bring more pieces to help more pieces
to
help okay look at all the how are you
just ignoring all my my whole Squad is
over there
I want to take
space wow I mean I got to go for it
right I I feel like we have to
okay
I really feel like this is a nice
example of black has an initiative yeah
black definitely has an ini black has an
initiative but can black capitalize on
this initiative I don't
know the problem with having a position
like this is you feel a lot of pressure
to do something if I was black I want to
end the game like right now you want to
end the game right now yeah
okay let's see what can I
do okay I'll do that okay try roll up
the sleeves okay yeah that's the chess
player sign of focus just yeah and you R
just SLE I guess I have to defend my
Pawn I mean don't really want to but
fine
now I'll will be anointed
take us much pieces
off I will take back would have been
nice if you didn't but okay now maybe we
go
up and I will take that PA that was all
part of the plan was very greedy move of
you all right let's see here now I'll
take a p all right let's see
[Music]
what I'm
scared okay can do that yes do that the
board looks different in this
building are you up a pawn
no six six each we
[Music]
good
um ah that king of yours just saying
just saying that king of yours come back
come back I go
forward no
o I have to block with my Rook this is
the tiny game in the tournament all over
again
no
I almost lost on time yeah I have no
idea what to do me too by the way
ah that is your Rook trapped but like I
can't actually take it that's so weird
check wait
what
okay oh I like having more time that's
nice think I'll take those
pawns can I like go eat the other ponds
no I
can't keep going whoa yes keep going no
I can stop you I yes I can
can you wait can you ah
okay oh my gosh no my Bishop nice game
game oh that was
crazy generally in five levels level
five is the ultimate master the person
that's played the game 20 30 years has
the highest pedigree actually that's you
in this case and we're still on level
four because computers have been better
than humans at chess for like 30 years
how has it changed the way you approach
the game yeah I mean I think chess
players are using computers intensively
all the time obviously with some
material odds it's going to be one part
of the training and other part of the
training that I find interesting is like
you know to find positions from let's
say real life tournaments and i' I've
been doing that actually from this
recent tournament that's going on in
Isle of Man playing out some of those
fascinating positions and just seeing
what the computer does and he's like
coming up with resources that you would
never think of you know today we've been
talking a lot about how chess is kind of
a mix of tactics versus strategy let's
elevate that discussion so what is chess
to you well the way my coach explained
chess to me that uh really seems
intuitive is that chess is a game of
time space and Harmony you have one turn
to get things done right obviously you
try to make it as efficient as possible
we have the saying in chess that you
know you lost by one tempo by one move
space you know we have a game of 64
squares right so control over these 64
squares of what the game is about you
can get control moving up your pawns you
can get control by winning a opponent's
material right so obviously that's
another big element that we're fighting
over and Harmony is basically like you
got this Army of pieces right your job
is to make them work well with each
other coordinate them and build that
beautiful picture of Harmony that you
know all chess players aim for and are
so pleased when they can finally achieve
so I've never thought of Chess that way
this is very interesting to me so of
those three what would you say is the
one that you have more Mastery over than
the other Harmony trumps everything it
trumps like you could be winning when
it's not your return and you're like
totally behind in material so it shows
you that Harmony is the end goal chess
is a miniature life I always like to say
that chess exposes all of your flaws on
the board your training habits in the
way you approach certain positions so
you say you can see yourself on the
chessboard who is enena on the
chessboard yeah well I think enena is a
fighter you know enena is not someone
who likes to give up Irina is someone
who wants to leave everything on the
board right like every last drop that's
the that's the idea how do you see
yourself as a player I think I like to
be creative so I find fun in Chess By
learning 10 different openings trying
different positions I like chaotic
positions I like positions where I can
attack I like positions where I'm
getting attacked and I can maybe defend
and find some creative way to turn
things around and I really really
struggle when I need to sit there and
just do nothing so you know we have
opposite Styles Levy I think our Blitz
game is going to be a lot of fun all
right
if I had to guess I I'd guess you're a
king's Indian player no I I see that's
an opening that requires a lot of uh
time and practice and dedication and I'm
but I'll I'll play something also still
fun okay the Dutch
defense is that the Leningrad I think G6
is Leningrad this this I don't I don't
I've tried to find a name I don't
actually know the name of this one I
guess there's also like the Stonewall
right you can play
yeah all right let's go for the most
solid move that's not fun we don't want
double pawns no we don't I would have
liked double
pawns okay let's complete that Bishop
fenet okay so you actually play The
Dutch that's not just like today's
surprise I play like a lot of openings
poorly that's my approach to chess I
just play things that I think will be
fun then the game starts going and I'm
like why did I play this I should learn
real openings
[Music]
okay I guess
I'll
yeah this is yeah nice and nice and
boring yeah prefer it wasn't
boring I think I got to do something
like on the queen side here before you
get your E5 moveing I was debating
playing
a55 question is is E5 a good move or a
bad move there's only one way to find
out so yeah you're going to go for it
yeah all right well I got to take
you can I take with the pawn probably E5
looks a little dangerous
but guess we can analyze that later all
right so what are you threatening at the
moment not much yeah if I take an E5 it
gets very boring I can also do something
like now it's a good thing that like my
queen is not going to hang when you take
my night yes oh well it's not it's
actually it's not a good thing I would
have preferred that it might you know it
might hang
but we only have like 90 seconds we have
to make conversation and also play some
semi- decent that's what streamers do
right like back I do YouTube you
know okay I think we can yeah got to
save my queen so we're going to
recapture like that what if I do this
what if I just don't acknowledge what
you're trying that's interesting right
cuz I don't have A3 I can play B5 was
kind of
interesting
yeah I have
C6 but you can play
B6 I can take on
D6 looks a little
boring not plausible
the average player would want five more
minutes now I think I think this move is
kind of interesting so we're going to go
for that okay it's a pawn sacrifice yeah
sort of temporary but I'm trying to keep
your Rook closed guess I take right I
feel like that's so we're trying to get
the pawn back I think this idea to keep
talking during the game was really good
by me yes I strategize before the game
started I play best when I have no time
on the clock that's uh so if I take an
F7 you take with the king so I don't
really get anywhere with that so I guess
I got to take this Pawn so I I was going
for this position I kind of like it okay
I think my plan here was to go here then
your C7 Pawn Yeah is is kind of stuck
forever plus to get the tempo on your
Rook oh Bishop D5 is always an idea
too
oh
wow I think you got some isues here Levy
think you should just think for like 47
more seconds and then then you should
make your decision all right
h i mean I have some really tempting
moves
here this was just information overload
just give too many possibilities and
then all right all right it's kind of
hard to decide
here let's not try not to win the game
right
away wow that surprised me you're
sacking The Exchange all right yes I
will okay do we just go for
counterplay maybe going for counterplay
was not very
smart maybe it was like very not smart M
wow okay okay so I guess we should bring
the Rooks
in this is the most fun part of the game
when you have 4 seconds you just have to
very fun um okay this Mo like really
terrible let's just do
it now the game could theoretically go
sorry
that's no
fun no it's like a really important Pond
there no and that pond is also really
important why would you take both of my
really important FS yeah yeah yeah
okay and I lost on time double wh that
was exciting though this was probably my
best move of the the game right and
taking my Rook yeah yes yeah this is the
subtle stuff Levy that we you know build
a game out of yeah but I think yeah but
it's ugly it's ugly because just in
general like this position I think is
kind of ugly yes you know you're stuck
with this Pawn you're stuck with this
Pawn question King should you play A4
because if you don't play A4 now can I
play a can you play A4 yeah that's a
question I mean okay like so like you
mean if I let you play a move like that
I still think like you're going to feel
like now I you're going to have like
more problems like even if I have like a
pawn here it's still annoying but then
if I start generating some some play
yeah you can try a little trap you see
it do you see it do you see that Bishop
this position is not not fun it's tough
because you got some issues with the
King some issues with the Rook with the
pawns you know but I think yeah like in
terms exposes who you are as a person I
just have many issues that's what your
move was interesting and it kind of
posed this this uh big decision in front
of me right like over here so I think in
terms of like strategy this was really
the key moment strategically because I
have to like make this big decision with
the pawn structure and so this one kind
of prevented your Rook from opening up
on this file and I I keep my pressure on
the queen side so this is a perfect
example of time space and Harmony Allin
one move yeah that's right that's right
we're fighting for space we're fighting
to not let the opponent build Harmony
yeah B5 I didn't even consider I just
thought you would either take or push or
but yeah this game went more in my style
of I listen to you carefully talk about
all all the things that you liked about
Chess and I tried I now I know what to
do against it that's what always happens
okay I have a personal question now yeah
you are the eight time United States
women's chess champion you also have the
highest title in all of Chess
Grandmaster I'm an eternal runnerup like
what is the championship mentality and
how have you succeeded at it so many
times in terms of The Grandmaster title
that's like um I think everyone's
personal Journey right it can take some
people longer I actually did it very
late in my life I don't know Levy if you
know this but I made grandmas when I was
29 most people if they don't do it by
the time they're like 20 they'll
probably never do it in terms of
becoming a grandmas really it's like
that that's the time and the commitment
I think if you're an international
Master like you are like everything is
Within Reach like you're already play
chess long enough in your life you're
close enough to that level that really
it's going to be little things like
putting in the time going to the best
tournaments and getting the best
competition and just maybe getting a
good coach to help you as well so I it's
not too late Levy okay we're going to
look forward to Gotham chess making
grandmas yeah then I'll retire and I
don't know do horse racing or
something tell me a little bit about
yourself do you play chess so I do play
chess um I played as a kid I remember
learning from my grandfather when we
lived in in India but I got recently
more interested in it when my kids
started playing chess in school in New
York kids play Chess at a very young age
one was my heart and it it's you know it
gets more and more intense and he's
playing tournaments and I thought let me
try to keep up with him and I realized
that I could kind of do it in my work as
well because I study Ai and I study um
computer science in general what type of
AI are we talking chat Bots we talking I
don't I I don't know the terms there's
all kinds so I try to create what I call
human oriented AI so I try to use AI to
understand human behavior what makes
humans decide and make the decisions
they that they do and we thought
wouldn't it be interesting to try to
create an AI that actually tries to play
like humans at different levels and
tries to mimic their behavior so that's
we what we set out to do with Maya
generally the chess board does not care
you feel I think is how AI plays right
it's sort of just figuring out the best
move you're right that AI is trying to
play the best way possible and it's
combining this evaluation function with
this the search it's powering it with
Brute Force like it can do millions of
searches a second I think some of the
components of the evaluation function
map to some of the things humans do when
they look at a chessboard right when
they're thinking about their King being
unsafe even that emotion you described
feel uncomfortable like I feel
uncomfortable whenever I've castled and
I push that gpon or something but that
feeling translates to some of the
components of the evaluation function
that's stockfish uses humans don't have
this luxury of searching millions of
nodes a second I can't even finish one
node without going oh what about the
second node right as you get deeper and
deeper the tree it just grows and grows
expands like combinator and it starts
getting very confusing and your
evaluation starts getting less and less
accurate you might make mistakes because
you might miss something and less and
less confident which is an emotion which
the computer doesn't feel one thing that
we noticed when I was talking with a
colleague of mine his name is Ashton
Anderson he's a professor at University
of Toronto he was in my lab and we both
had this passion for chess but we
realized no one had really used AI to
play like a human would play I think my
audience once pulled 92% are below the
level of 1,00 but it's really hard to
learn chess because you don't get to
experience learning content based on
people who are your level like how did
you really deduce how a 1200 will play
we use state-ofthe-art neural networks
like Alpha Zer and Lela but we Instead
try to predict what move a human would
make given a board position is these
deep neural Nets are kind of like black
boxes so we've come up with interesting
ways to prob at them to get an idea of
okay what Isa is going on that is
different about this person or different
about that person we had like a style
vctor for each person we can compare
those see where you defer and try to map
those back to human understandable chess
Concepts because that's a key right if I
just tell you oh they theer and the
third number and the fifth number you'll
be like what does that even mean right
but if I can tell you oh I think this
person worries more about their King
safety or sacrifices their Center at the
cost of protecting their king or
something like that some kind of
trade-off then you might be able
understand what's what's going on there
so that's what we're trying to do now
with with these style vectors and the
fun thing about having numbers
representing people is that you can add
them together you can mix them with
something like like Maya do you think
it's possible to develop some sort of
accurate measure let's say I'm a 1200 I
have an opening course I just want to
practice my opening yeah can I do it
some way against Maya or I think that's
actually a good idea and I agree with
you that it's not something you can
easily access today and like out with
the online tools and the chess platforms
that are out there I play the Caron and
when I learned it I started getting
afraid of so when you go I started
getting afraid of yeah the advance the
advance and even more so at some point
when I like I I always like to get my
Bishop out because I feel very
uncomfortable if I don't and then
eventually something happens this Pond
making its way over here used to scare
me and I never experienced this in any
you know looking at the openings and
because I would not know what to do I
would take it I would get in trouble and
even if they if I let them take I would
yeah you'd have to move your king my
king and so I remember hitting all these
variations that just that just scared me
pawn to E5 on the third move is the most
challenging move against the carocon it
restricts the KN and the main line so
the move is bringing out this so you
don't get locked right I play that move
but the move that I also added to my
toolbox and is the only move I teach now
is this move to to try to undermine the
center it's not commonly played at the
highest level if you study Master games
this is probably one in every six games
or something compared to right so now we
go down a totally different path we're
taking a totally different train to our
destination but just this undermining of
the position you know splitting up these
pawns and then slowly capturing them
both that does wonders at intermediate
and early Advance level this move
despite it being move three according to
databases already give gives black like
a 53% chance of winning which is crazy
because normally white is about
52% white just doesn't know what to do
is that like like human empirically
though based on the games that people
are play yeah like I would say is a
stockfish ofal like we uh for black
computer computer after like 12 13 moves
says white is better white is better
okay but what does that really mean
right in practice in practice yeah even
in Grandmaster level chess okay move 13
white is better and move 20 black is
equal I love this because this is an
example of the kind of advice at as you
said in the intermediate and advanced
level that could be appropriate because
you're thinking about the human opponent
that you're playing and maybe you
wouldn't recommend this at the highest
highest levels but in that range I think
it could very well be very good advice
and as they get more comfortable with it
and understand it your students at some
point they might realize you know what
I've progressed to a point where I don't
want to play that anymore and they'll
change but for a good part of time it
could be very uh useful for them in
1997 Kasparov lost to deep blue we can
say for about 26 years now ai has been
better than humans in chess but where do
we go from here thinking about Chess
first of all I have to hand it to Alpha
zero and and Leela and these other
engines because I think they have
sometimes given us interesting ideas
they've shown Sparks of creativity that
have inspired the way humans play in but
I agree with you that right now you know
you look at the the tcac competitions
and they're just kind of getting better
and better a little bit better a little
bit better a little bit more data maybe
a deeper newal Network and you know
these advances I don't find that
interesting I'm more interested in
trying to get better and better at
creating humanlike presence and
human-like avatars when it comes to
chess or when it comes to other games so
I feel like you know within 5 years
we'll probably have a lot of human like
like entities that we can interact in in
Virtual settings not just because of the
rise of large language models and the
ability to converse and speak and
produce texts like humans but hopefully
the ability to produce actions like
humans too I hope you enjoyed this
episode of five levels and before you go
I just want to say that it's probably
one of the most unique episodes because
our ages did not go up from low age to a
higher age chess doesn't really care
about any of that just give it a try it
is ever evolving and The Learning
Journey is really never over when you
play
[Music]
chess